now I would like to welcome our
presenters to start we have Professor
will chew a he is an associate professor
in the department of material science
and engineering a senior fellow of the
Precourt Institute for energy here at
Stanford University and the co-director
of the storage axe initiative at
Stanford University he is also a faculty
scientist at United States Department of
Energy's SLAC National Accelerator lab
he leads a research group of more than
40 tackling the challenge of
decarbonisation of using various energy
transformation pathways will is an
expert on the science and engineering of
batteries fuel cells and related
electrochemical technologies also with
us today is Diane grunick she a Precourt
energy scholar at the Precourt Institute
for energy of energy at Stanford
University and a commissioner emeritus
of the California Public Utilities
Commission Diane is an internationally
recognized energy expert has worked on
energy policy for over four decades and
has received numerous awards for her
work on energy efficiency including the
30th anniversary award of the American
Council for an energy-efficient economy
for outstanding contributions and it's
national champion of energy efficiency
award
she's also received the National
Association of regulatory utility
commissioners clean energy award and the
EE global forms first visionary award
for leadership in developing the
California long term energy efficient
strategic plan she has also served on
external advisory committees to the US
Department of Energy and the National
Renewable Energy Lab and is a senior
fellow with the new buildings Institute
our third presenter today Steve Camillo
is the lead energy business innovation
that is the lead for the energy business
and
a focus area at the Stanford Graduate
School of Business
Steve leads the energy business focus
area and is a senior research fellow at
the Steyr Taylor Center for energy
policy and finance
he is also type a techno economic and
policy lead for the Stanford
University's Precourt Institute for
energy bits and Watts initiatives and
store Jack's initiative his work exams
how technology policy and organizations
co-evolved to influence the business
models and economic attractiveness of
advanced energy solutions he advises
academic industry government and
non-governmental organizations on
strategies for clean technology
deployment within his current portfolio
he explores policy and business model
innovation within the electricity sector
with one set of projects focusing on how
digital platform technology diffuses
intersects with structural changes in
the industry to start today we'll will
talk about the energy industry and its
transformation as well as the energy
courses we have offered here at Stanford
University for online education Annina
thank you very much for the introduction
and hello everyone and welcome
so as anita mentioned we are here to
talk about energy innovations and I am
the academic director of the EIT the
energy innovation and emerging
technology program so I thought I might
begin with just highlighting a few
important trends happening at energy and
then tried to tell you a little bit more
about how everyone could be contributing
towards solutions for these pressing
problems so in the past decade we have
seen some tremendous opportunities and
trends in energy for example we are
seeing the emergence of low cost natural
gas Sushil we have witnessed the
explosion of electric vehicles thanks to
the decreasing in the cost of battery
technologies the market for lithium-ion
batteries
increase from fifty million dollar it is
today to over a trillion dollar in the
next ten to fifteen years we have also
seen in the past decade the tremendous
decrease in the cost of wind and solar
renewable electricity now becoming
competitive if not more than competitive
in certain market areas with
conventional fossil based electricity
and we're also seeing tremendous
opportunities for energy innovations in
developing countries such as India and
in China and for today's presentation
will be learning about building energy
efficiency and there there are also some
extremely exciting trends for example in
2017 the building energy efficiency area
added more new jobs than any other
industry in the US energy sector in 2018
more than 400 billion dollar were spent
in building energy inefficiency alone so
these are some of the exciting
opportunities that Diana Steve will
discuss today the purpose of our online
education program at EIU T is to empower
those of you who want to learn more
about how you can contribute I often
like to say that it will be wonderful if
all of us can roll up our sleeves and
contribute something toward the solution
you might be an engineer or a scientist
looking into clean tech and thinking
about how to develop technologies
necessary for the transition you may be
working in the policy area thinking
about how to implement and incentivize
some of these transformation that is
needed you could be an intrapreneur of
looking at new business opportunities
and commercializing new areas business
opportunity and technology so no matter
what you're interested in I think you'll
find something interesting in our
collection of courses which you can see
on this flight now the course really
covers many aspects of energy technology
and you know
whether it's the technology the policy
the finance aspect which Diana Steve
will also talk about today in the
context of building energy and
efficiency and we discuss topics such as
solar fossil especially in terms of
natural gas the electricity grid energy
storage wind water economics behavior
building efficiency of course and then
we have new courses coming online on
electric vehicles as well I think you
will find many of this course will get
into not only that deep aspects of the
problem involved but it will also give
you the bird's eye view of what can be
done for all of us to contribute let me
end on the note by saying that a huge
amount of work is being done to help us
get to the aggressive energy efficiency
and emission goals that we have set
forth but we're very far from reaching
it and I think all of us can do
something to contribute and I'm
extremely delighted to welcome Diane and
Steve to talk about one important aspect
of energy innovation in terms of
building energy efficiency so Diane and
thank you thank you this is Diane I'll
get started and if you are able to stay
till the end of today's webinar we're
going to give you a brief overview of
the different modules in the online
course that we've developed here at
Stanford but for today we decided to
just pick out a couple areas that we do
touch upon in more depth and that's new
frontiers and opportunities because for
those of you who may have heard of an
energy efficiency or building energy
efficiency you may not be aware of just
how quickly this whole area is involving
not just in terms of technology but
policy and finance so we're very excited
today to be presenting this particular
information that we go into more detail
in the course so this webinar will give
you
a level overview of emerging
opportunities in building energy
efficiency we're gonna start off with
covering motivations for pursuing
building energy efficiency and then
we're gonna briefly describe our
approach in this area four key elements
and three dimensions and why this
approach is unique and necessary for
unlocking the great potential of
building energy efficiency and then
we'll take a look at two of the major
building energy efficiency areas that
are rapidly emerging and now how
everyone can seize opportunities in
those areas and finally we'll finish
with some question and answer so let's
begin with motivations for focusing on
building energy efficiency and why it's
an area of significant growth and will
be even more so in the coming years as
we'll mention that the outset building
energy efficiency is a massive industry
globally with over 425 billion in 2018
spending according to the International
Energy Agency this spending includes
deployment of solutions across a wide
variety of components and systems such
as building envelope lighting plug loads
HVAC controls building management
systems and very advanced intelligent
efficiency as well now second and
looking at the United States
specifically again as will mention in
2017 energy efficiency added more new
jobs than any other industry in the
entire u.s. energy sector in 2018
building energy efficiency employed over
2.3 million people in the United States
and in 2019 this number was projected to
grow by almost 8 percent making building
energy efficiency one of the fastest
growing areas in energy so let's take a
look in another way in keeping with the
u.s. for a moment longer energy
efficiency has had an impressive impact
on reducing the consumption of enter
and saving money this graph shows that
in 2014
energy efficiency interventions save 58
quadrillion BTUs of energy taking 1980
as a baseline put another way the u.s.
consumed 37 percent less energy in 2014
than it would have absent energy
efficiency using 1980 as a baseline in
terms of economic savings on average
every person in the United States in
2014 alone saved almost 2,500 dollars in
avoided energy costs and bipartisan
legislation now before the US Congress
that would boost energy efficiency in
homes and other buildings could save an
additional 51 billion dollars on US
energy bills through 2050 now fourth and
finally let's look at the role of energy
efficiency in dealing with climate
change looking at the scenario of annual
global emissions created by the
International Energy Agency energy
efficiency will be needed to contribute
44% of the reduction in co2 emissions
about the same as all renewables and
carbon capture technologies combined
this role is needed both to reduce and
avoid emissions but also to avoid having
to make investments in more costly
supply-side
options so while energy efficiency has
had a great history of accomplishment
the climate crisis necessitates multiple
step changes in development deployment
and market transformation and this is
the tremendous opportunity for energy
efficiency and building energy
efficiency in particular that has us
truly excited and we hope you will be as
well
Steve I said so for building energy
efficiency interventions to be effective
we teach that there are four key
elements that must be understood in
isolation
combination in order to design and
implement solutions that meet cost
emissions and other kinds of targets
both initially and persistently the
first key element is the building's now
this is where the sites for any building
energy efficiency intervention occurs we
distinguish across four kinds of
buildings residential commercial
industrial and Civic or special now
central questions about buildings that
require clarity include what are their
purposes how are they currently used and
how will they be programmed in the
future connected to buildings is the
next key element which is the
stakeholders these are all the actors
who have direct and indirect influence
on the building energy efficiency
intervention from conceptualization to
design from sales and implementation to
post implementation and ongoing
operation validation and assessment now
central questions concerning
stakeholders include how do stakeholders
relate to each other what authorities
and powers do they have and how do you
accommodate preferences and requirements
the answers to these questions need to
be considered throughout the entire life
cycle of the project
third is the motivations of the key
decision-makers groups or entities which
are often not the eventual occupants of
the building our cost and energy savings
the only criteria
what about non-energy benefits such as
health and productivity energy security
economic and social development how are
these motivations articulated and
understood and in what ways do these
bias or constrained building energy
efficiency solutions finally the fourth
element is the barriers building energy
efficiency is rife with market
structural institutional and behavioral
barriers that shape the kinds of the
solutions available the difficulty of
implementation and the ultimate ultimate
success both in this short and long term
together these four elements form the
basis for understanding building energy
efficiency as a concept absent
understanding and addressing each of
these elements projects will likely not
succeed so given the complexity of the
building energy efficiency space we
introduced
teach an integrated approach that
incorporates three levers technology
policy and finance these are the key
dimensions that must be appreciated to
successfully design develop and deploy
building energy efficiency interventions
now specifically these are the lenses
through which to view the four elements
we just spoke about again building
stakeholders motivations and barriers to
understand or select the appropriate
mechanisms and tools to create solutions
that meaningfully and persistently
address energy cost climate and other
dimensions now moreover this integrated
approach emphasizes the interactions
across these three dimensions to provide
a holistic view of building energy
efficiency and thereby increasing the
effectiveness and probability of success
of the project so looking at the cross
influence of technology and policy
policy provides the incentives penalties
and information that shapes the kinds of
technological solutions that can be
developed while technology provides
policy makers and regulators the
knowledge about how stringent to set
policy policy goals and what kinds of
solutions might be used to achieve such
goals looking at the cross influence of
Technology and finance all things being
equal
advances in technology increase the
probability that savings will occur for
more efficient components and systems
particularly when there is widespread
adoption and market experience this is
what we mean by being bankable that a
financier would have high confidence in
the performance of the technology in
meeting energy efficiency goals and thus
lower the financing cost of the energy
efficiency intervention at the same time
financing is able to match the stream of
benefits of energy efficiency
technologies with the cost of acquiring
and operating them this is crucial and
getting new technologies to market and
to help them gain traction now however
the benefits to new energy efficiency
technologies and interventions are not
the only save and are not only saved
energy and lower energy bill costs there
are the non-energy benefits such as
comfort and lower onm cost that are
often critical to
customers and end users and
understanding these areas are key from
focusing development on technology
finally the third intersection is that
between policy and finance just as they
do for technology policy tools a
combination of incentives penalties and
information support and enable building
energy efficiency financing mechanisms
and market investment and in turn
financing provides funding to implement
policies and incentives to align
behaviors and transform markets dan
thanks we know we've covered a lot in
just the last several slides in minutes
but we wanted to set the stage to give
you a sense of in the online course how
we approach it and especially the fact
that we're trying to look at this area
of building energy efficiency in a
multi-dimensional
approach because that is what both
historically has made it successful but
looking forward in the ways we're going
to talk about today with the new
frontiers it's really bringing together
these four different dimensions as well
as the three actual tools that we use so
I'm gonna before we get into our very
exciting new frontiersman just a moment
on talking about an example that has
been very successful historically that
brings these understandings together and
this is about refrigerators it's one of
my favorite stories because it shows
through California's groundbreaking
efforts in energy efficiency
how technology and policy combined have
led to lower costs and how better
products for consumers in the
environment have also emerged so let's
start with the energy use of
refrigerators increase steadily in the
United States from the 1940s up until
1975 in 1975 a state agency here in
California the California Energy
Commission developed what has now become
globally a key building energy
efficiency policy tool introducing the
first appliance standards ever and did
so for refrige
so let's see what happened with that
policy tool since 1975 California and
the federal government have tightened
refrigerator standards on a regular
basis due to better technology coming
into the market but that's not the only
story
the average refrigerator cost as shown
in this slide on Green has fallen
dramatically in the 45 years since the
standards were first set so that now
consumers pay much less for efficient
refrigerators than they did for
inefficient ones and the final part of
the story is that the size of the
refrigerators has increased steadily it
has leveled off only due to the size of
doors preventing bigger refrigerators
from getting into kitchens and now not
shown on this chart the trend has
continued by 2013 the electricity used
for the average new refrigerator in the
United States had decreased to about
three-quarters of its 1973 level even
though refrigerators had increased in
average size and decreased in inflation
adjusted price costs falling to about
10% of what they were six years earlier
so this example demonstrates how
building energy efficiency must involve
an understanding and strategies
integrated across technology policy and
economics and while we don't have time
to go into it today the success story of
refrigerators is also due to the focus
on the five key elements in building
energy efficiency that Steve's mentioned
buildings themselves stakeholders
motivations and barriers Steve back to
you thanks Ann so we've discussed the
motivations for focusing on building
energy efficiency the four key elements
of every project the integrative
approach we teach to enable successful
solutions and an example of how the
elements and tools of Technology Policy
and finance have worked together in the
except refrigerators now we turn to the
very exciting future new frontiers and
opportunities for building energy
efficiency our course teaches three
areas that are rapidly emerging as
significant opportunities for building
energy efficiency in the coming decade
they are intelligent efficiency building
decarbonisation and energy efficiency as
a climate mitigation strategy in this
webinar we will very briefly touch upon
two of them intelligent efficiency and
building decarbonisation so let's spend
a couple of minutes first on intelligent
efficiency so we borrowed the definition
of intelligent efficiency from the
leading energy efficiency research
organization in the u.s. the American
Council for an efficient for an
energy-efficient economy AC Triple E as
an aside the first module in our course
includes an interview with AC tripolis
executive director Steve medel as well
as with Stanford professor Nobel Prize
winner and former US Secretary of Energy
Steve Chu AC Triple E defines
intelligent efficiency as the additional
energy efficiency that is possible with
information and communications
technologies also known as ICT such as
sensors connected devices networks and
data analytics intelligent efficiency is
a systems-based
holistic approach to energy savings
enabled by ICT and user access to
real-time or near real-time information
intelligent efficiency or ie is a
tremendous growth area in building
energy efficiency a consequence of the
digital transformation that is sweeping
across all sectors within energy and
beyond with the simultaneous advancement
and access to data algorithms networks
the cloud and specialized cost-effective
Hardware so let's quickly walk through
how all of these intelligent efficiency
components can come together for
building energy efficiency first we have
data produced by the devices and streams
indicated here in red these include
solar panels smart thermos
that's plug load controls and other data
feeds a key data stream is added utility
data which is enabled by smart meters
which not only record energy consumption
at a high frequency but also allow for
two-way communication of said data a key
question is who controls the data and
how this is related to two of the
elements that were key in building
energy efficiency stakeholders and
barriers and should be viewed through
the lenses of both technology and policy
now these data are shared via a network
shown here in the black arrows using
both wired and wireless communication
technologies perhaps from data feeds
from services outside of the building
like weather data analytics is performed
using algorithms within systems shown
here in the purple circles with examples
including energy information systems
energy management information systems
and building automation systems this is
where input data is analyzed and
displayed in network and proprietary
clouds to enable a corrective response
if needed these analytics can ingest and
process literally millions of data
points depending on the complexity of
the system and they provide a real-time
or near real-time situational awareness
of the building all the way down to the
individual component or device level now
such analytics could also forecast how a
building is likely to behave based on
historical patterns and may allow for
more flexible load that could benefit
the grid as a whole and it's imperative
to consider the building type
stakeholders and barriers that may
influence the kinds of analytics
performed and interpreted and how
decisions to act upon recommendations
will emerge finally we have the physical
devices they can either be sensors
creating the data about the building in
the first place or actuators which make
changes automatically or otherwise in
response to signals sent from the
information systems now what I've just
sketched for you is the outline of a
smart building a system that provides
useful feedback about the operation of a
building coupled with the ability to
make fine-tuned adjustments to optimize
for comfort cost in
and energies as you can well imagine an
integrated approach that makes explicit
the four elements we outlined earlier
and considers their implications through
an integrated approach is crucial to
develop and implement solutions that are
meaningful measurable and persistent now
back to Diane thank you I want to just
spend a minute Steve what you were
talking about health our audience just
understand why we put such emphasis on
the dimensions like what are the
different types of buildings or the
stakeholders involved if you've looked
at what Steve has shown us today just
think of how many different technical
areas there are in the buildings that
you need to understand and the different
stakeholders and job classifications of
people involved and then think also
about how policies have to start to
change to be dynamic enough that they
can take advantage of the new technology
coming in that the type of policies that
we've had in the past say for a light
bulb to incent the production of LEDs is
vastly different from the type of
policies to get this type of technology
installed and then an area of specialty
for Steve in particular finance is how
are you going to bring together this new
technology and having finance friendly
policies and that's again part of why we
wanted to select this particular example
in intelligent efficiency to show what a
rapidly changing area this is and the
new opportunities that you can think are
developing across whole range of
occupations so now I'll turn to for just
a minute our next area that we picked
out both for the course and for talking
about today which is very new building
decarbonization so I'm going to take a
moment just to explain what it is
because even though I've been involved
in this area for over 40 years it's
really something that's just emerged in
the last three or four years in terms of
really a focus buildings account for
almost 40 percent of global carbon
dioxide emissions that's something to
really keep in mind
but there are two sources of greenhouse
gas emissions associated with buildings
the first are direct building emission
sources like gas furnaces gas water
heaters and gas stoves all of which
produce emissions within buildings but
then there's a second the indirect
emissions produced by the production and
transport of electricity and natural gas
to our buildings for the natural gas
system methane leakage is a major source
of emissions and on the electric system
it's generally power plant emissions so
building decarbonisation means
decreasing the greenhouse gas emissions
associated with buildings by three steps
the first is deep building energy
efficiency for example a building that
uses less electricity because it has
efficient lighting and deep building
energy efficiency decreases both direct
and indirect building emissions now the
second is decarbonizing our grid thereby
decreasing indirect emissions but the
third is strategic electrification
within the building or changing fuel
types for the building and uses which
focuses on the fuels used within the
building and avoiding or eliminating
their emissions so now let me take a
minute to talk about why Billy
decarbonisation is so important this
slide comes from the California Energy
Commission it models a two-story house
in Sacramento using the highly efficient
California 2020 title 24 building
standards the slide the chart on the
Left models a very efficient home but it
is a dual fuel home using both
electricity and natural gas for water
and space heating the chart
the monthly and annual emissions from
the house on the right side the same
sized house and location is modeled but
for an all-electric house in other words
instead of a gas-fired water heater and
furnace electric heat pumps are modeled
as well as induction cooking in lieu of
a gas fired stove the results are
dramatic the all-electric home has a 60%
reduction of water heating emissions and
70% reduction in space heating emissions
and that in a nutshell is why building
decarbonisation has so much focus and
attention right now when we are dealing
with our global climate crisis further
building decarbonisation is an excellent
example for understanding building
energy efficiency through the lens of
the three dimensions that we teach in
our course and provides very exciting
opportunities for each of the three
areas let me take you through them very
very briefly technology is critical
especially smart electric heat pumps
where the technology exists but
improvements through solid performance
tests lowered cost and grid integration
capabilities are needed improvements are
also needed to reduce hydrofluorocarbon
HFC emissions enlarged cooling systems
and in heat pumps so that's technology
we could give many more examples but
that's really what we have time for
today let's turn to policy our second
dimension that's where it is very
critical because building
decarbonisation will not happen without
critical policy changes examples include
setting targets and developing roadmaps
but also key changes in rate design and
something that does not make greater use
of electrical devices in our buildings
cost prohibitive and what we're seeing
increasingly is that many local
governments are reviewing building codes
to require or encourage all new electric
buildings with a lot of differentiation
and how they're approaching it but again
looking at the policy tool of building
codes and thinking about how that can be
used to integrate with the new
technologies coming into this space as
well as the existing technologies that
we have
and then finally finance will have a
major role including carbon price
signals wholesale market incentives for
grid level load management services and
methodologies that value non-energy
benefits associated with building
decarbonisation an aspect of finance
that Steve briefly mentioned but we
really try to go into detail more in
this course so in short there is much
work to be done to create rapid building
decarbonisation market transformation so
for those of you with us today who are
interested in building energy efficiency
we hope you're excited about the
tremendous opportunities in just these
two areas and new frontiers that we've
talked about if you are interested in
learning more about intelligent
efficiency and building decarbonisation
and a whole host of other topics related
to building energy efficiency then we
invite you to take our course here's an
overview of the course content there are
seven substantive modules plus one
wrap-up that each material covering
basic concepts in depth review including
many case studies of the dimensions of
technology policy and finance and the
advanced topics we touched upon here as
well as specifics on the role of energy
efficiency in global climate change
efforts all in about six-and-a-half
hours of lecture time Steve so one last
element that we want to emphasize before
we open up the Q&A is the numerous
International industry experts from
academia policy business and advocacy
that we interview in the course hearing
from them provides unique insights into
this often complex and rapidly changing
area so in combination our course
provides a comprehensive invaluable view
on how to think about building energy
efficiency how to identify challenges
and how the opportunity space is rapidly
expanding around the globe
so with that we're happy to take
questions now thank you
Stan and Steve and will for getting us
started and providing this very
important information for our attendees
today
thank you very much Anita and diancie
thank you very much for the informative
webinar so there are a quite a number of
questions and I have I'm going to read
them out here so the first question
concerns what innovative financial
mechanisms are emerging beyond what has
been at play and that will drive the
enormous capital needed for customer to
move to large-scale clean energy
adoption sure so with what is in play
right now you have generally traditional
and non-traditional financing mechanisms
traditional ones are typical loans and
leases non-traditional or more
specialized like energy service
performance contracts and pace but
what's emerging right now is actually
energy service agreements and that's
essentially looking at energy efficiency
on a subscription model where
essentially
you are paying for the reduction of the
consumption of some elements say it's
energy say it's water something along
those lines and instead of being capital
intensive there is a company that you
just subscribe and you agree upon what
is the level of energy efficiency will
achieve and then that is essentially the
provider will will be able to hopefully
meet that goal and that is where it may
the cost effective for the receiving
entity to actually pay for this because
there is a reduction in the cost at the
same time they don't have to go and
search for the capital outlay that is
actually the responsibility of the
energy service agreement provider who
would probably be more savvy in trying
to find the capital that they can then
use to provide this subscription and
then they start getting cash flow from
the entity who's actually receiving
their there their services so one for
example is cooling as a service that is
something that is emerging cooling is
very very important especially as the
emerging economies seek to essentially
move and install air conditioning that
is as a first-time basis quite expensive
but if there are models that are able to
essentially allay that cost then those
are the ones that are actually seeing a
lot of uptake and you're seeing that in
India in some cases in China in some
cases in the southeast of the US thank
you Steve
dan would you like to add anything to
the finance mess what I would say is
that thinking back to what we talked
about earlier today on intelligent
efficiency that to me is where it's so
exciting to think about with intelligent
efficiency we're starting to build
buildings that are quite smart and
instead of being a black hole of what's
going on within them we understand a
great deal about individual components
as well as overall systems so you can
think about having that where does that
knowledge go now that we know what's
going on in buildings well it can go to
obviously in some aspects to people who
are in the buildings so that they
understand that they're feeling too hot
or too cold in different parts of the
building how systems can be adjusted it
can go to the building owners but it can
also go to third parties such as Steve
talked about where they're not just
again dealing with a black hole of where
they may have financed some aspects of
this smart building but understanding if
parts of it get out of whack
how you go in and do a fine to
retro-commissioning of different systems
and which ones need to be done
so it's essentially looking at the
various stakeholders involved within
uses in buildings bringing in new
technologies through intelligent
efficiency and then having that feedback
loop that helps on the financing to make
sure that we get the returns back to
those who have invested in buildings and
this again is just an example of why we
chose today to highlight on intelligent
efficiency because it really isn't just
about technology which is what you might
think it is but it's about the finance
and how that can open up areas as well
some of the new policies and you know
just the bill and how that you reminded
me so what I just described energy
service agreements for those who are in
the ESCO market that sounds pretty
similar but energy service agreements
are actually being targeted toward
residential buildings like single homes
or duplexes or small and medium
enterprises and those have typically
been locked out of what's called the
subscription model for energy efficiency
and because you have these lower cost
mechanisms to find information about the
building and you're able to then see
where an intervention might occur this
is why you're seeing this this move
toward making these smaller buildings
smarter and the smartness of the
building then allows the energy service
agreement to actually gain traction
thank you so in the webinar today you
really highlighted the interdisciplinary
nature of addressing building energy
efficiency so the next question touches
further upon this so the question is on
what how does the energy water Nexus fit
into building energy efficiency
specifically the embedded energy of
water I know that we didn't talk about
that today but I was wondering you can
comment on the importance of water as
well it's hugely important
I think Anita mentioned as part of my
back
I was a commissioner at the California
Public Utilities Commission where we
oversaw an energy efficiency annual
spending by investor-owned utilities in
California of over 1 billion dollars a
year and I was fortunate to be the
assignment commissioner and I actually
had some background in water as well as
energy so what we did was that we
brought in new policies that had
utilities in the water area start to
work with utilities in the energy area
to offer combined programs because you
actually have a lot of energy usage in
the production and in the conveyance of
what and distribution of water into our
buildings that I just looked at
California but it was a major area I
think it's well over ten percent maybe
even fifteen percent of electricity use
is actually related to the conveyance
and use of water so here's just some
quick examples of what can be done like
in the policy area you can set up
programs where electric utilities
actually provide rebates and incentives
for the installation of low-flow
showerheads because then again you can
think about that reduces the energy use
the water use in the building but
because you're having less water being
conveyed and distributed in the building
that also decreases the electric use and
that's something where internationally
we're seeing a lot of interests that
with climate change we are increasingly
looking at potentially some areas of
wide scale long duration droughts so we
want to think about our buildings in
terms of what are all the usages of our
resources within them and how can we
combine looking at both water and energy
in particular and I'll just end with one
thing that in the United States and on
ashlee elsewhere you have utilities that
sometimes provide both water and
electricity as well as sewage so you
want to bring them in as players that
are looking at a building in an
integrated fashion it just makes no
sense to go in and say hey how can we
reduce say how can we improve the
lighting without also saying at the same
time if you've gotten the occupants
engaged and thinking about improving
their buildings we want to think about
how across all these various areas they
they can become really helpful in
reducing usage and reducing our climate
emissions as well so that goes back to
you know what we what we talk about and
of course quite a bit is thinking about
again the elements who are the
stakeholders and how else can you bring
them along and if you can increase the
pool of stakeholders that would find an
intervention interesting then the
probability that it will get done
increases and you can actually save a
lot more energy or other or provide
other benefits than you didn't that you
would have otherwise thought about if
you just went after one specific kind of
stakeholder in the beginning so see
that's actually a great segue to the
next question
so one viewer asks what are some of the
non-energy benefits of building energy
efficiency that that you are looking at
and others are looking at so one one
example and and there's quite a few but
let's have a concrete example and let's
think about LED lights okay so we know
the LED light lights for the amount of
luminous flux or amount of light you get
out of it for the amount of energy you
put in it's much greater than an
incandescent bulb fine but a non energy
benefit is the O&M cost and so think
about what is the lifetime of a typical
incandescent light bulb versus LED you
have one that could last anywhere from
five hundred to a thousand hours versus
an LED which could last up to twenty
five thousand hours now just think about
all the instances of void
of someone going and changing that light
bulb right there's you being at home and
maybe you don't actually have a cost
function for that but if you're at a
large company and a large facility think
about all the avoided times where you
don't have to deploy crews especially if
they need to go up multiple feet to
essentially change that light bulb so
that's a kind of non energy benefit
where entered energy efficiency really
starts to pull out and that cost is much
greater that avoided cost in operations
and maintenance is much greater than the
actual energy saved and that's what
makes it compelling and that's where
I'll just mention why we focus a lot on
the integration because it's a non
energy benefit you can make sure that
it's really motivating and enhancing the
use of these example LEDs if you have
policies that instead of just valuing
the reduced electricity use in the
saving on energy bills that they can
also start to count and value some of
these non-energy benefits and that's
where we're just starting to see really
the intense work that needs to be done
to sure to ensure that there's rigor in
this area but these are real benefits
and people value them and so having
policies excuse me that can really also
provide that value are important and
then the other area that you've talked
about Steve is the finance side that
people again this can be a non energy
benefit but still providing an economic
value that then can be translated into
the financing that's given for that type
of intervention so that again is why we
emphasize so much the multi-dimensional
aspect of so many aspects in this area
speaking of the multi-dimensional aspect
of many of our viewers are from outside
of United States so I thought we might
take a moment and get a more
international view of the problem so one
viewer is asking how do you see some
the ideas discussed here today ward in
emerging markets like in Africa where
the scaling risk and finances are quite
challenging compared to the United
States also a few words and then Steve
please come in first of all is again in
in our course we very much have tried to
have information that is universal
globally that today we focused a bit on
some examples in the United States but
buildings exist everywhere and in fact
there's quite a difference between
developed countries where the issue
really is existing buildings and how are
you going to go in and make them
efficient and decrease their emissions
versus in developing countries Africa
China India where new buildings are
going to be built so let me start off as
specifically with the example with
Africa in some ways one aspect that can
be easier is we have made great leaps
forward in technology and so you can
have new buildings built in Africa or
elsewhere that are putting in super
efficient lighting LEDs from the
beginning and because the costs have
gone down you actually can have pretty
much a comparable use of LED lighting
versus the old-fashioned incandescent
and so that is where you need to have
certainly awareness education perhaps
some of the building codes that exist
throughout the world that say we're
going to start off with in the
developing countries with the new
buildings making sure the best
technology on the market is installed
and that's quite different from thinking
about in the United States where you
essentially have to get out the old
incandescent light bulbs and how do you
motivate as well sometimes mandate the
replacement in existing buildings of the
lighting system so that's really what I
would start off
is thinking about where the technologies
exist what are their cost and how do you
have awareness of them and then actual
support for their use India has had a
very successful program going on that
really has incented and motivated
usability Dee's on a scale we haven't
seen anywhere else in the world
did you want to add something yeah I
want to actually give a shout out to a
firm that was started by a GSB alum
Lauren Dunford and her husband that now
operates in Kenya the company is called
Safi analytics and essentially what it
does is for industrial buildings it goes
in there and essentially looks at where
are all the different loads and then
given how the loads are distributed and
what are the operations of the actual
facility what are ways that you can
actually reduce cost the simple fact of
just getting information going in there
putting a few sensors in and doing the
analytics that cost has gone from here
to here over the last few years so just
getting a sense for what is possible
getting that baseline information is
very very cost effective and then from
there you can make more informed
decisions and it's actually quite
amazing some of the interventions that
they've been able to unearth simply
because you would think that a building
would be operating quite efficiently
until you actually purposely put the
right sensors out there and see that
there's so much let's call it
low-hanging fruit and again it's by
distributed by deploying low-cost
digitalized technology to help you make
those really informed decisions I'll
mention just one other area that I think
is hugely important when we think about
outside of the United States and
globally and that is fully that with
climate change we are seeing increased
temperatures but we're also seeing a
rise of people wanting to have cooler
buildings and homes and so there we
again go into this in our course but
was adopted as an amendment to the
Montreal Protocol something called the
kigali amendment which is really the
analysis is shown that if we simply have
a world that is cooled with the types of
air conditioners we have now which not
only can be very inefficient but also
can release very serious greenhouse
gases we are going to have much less
time than we even have now to deal with
climate change and in fact we can't
approach the world of cooling the way we
have for the last 40 years so the kigali
amendment is about developing entire new
ways of thinking about cooling new
technologies but maybe even existing
technologies such as fans but that
become super efficient and also are
coupled with intelligence so this is an
area where it's we didn't have time
again today to select every area we
would have loved to have talked about
with new opportunities and frontiers but
there is literally millions of dollars
pouring into thinking about cooling
worldwide because of the kigali
Amendment and philanthropic efforts to
support it so anyone interested in
cooling we could go on and on about it
but it's a very important and critical
area so Steve and Diane you highlighted
the disparity in the approach for
building energy and efficiency
say between developed countries in
developing countries a one viewer also
asked specifically in South Korea that
building energy efficiency is lacking
behind and how would you suggest on
driving changes in government policies
specifically for South Korea I'll take
just a little bit again to talk about in
the course we have as we mention
different modules and there's a specific
module on policy I joked that this was
like my magnum opus after working in
this area for 40 years to try to
summarize
but one of the areas that I teach about
is not just what are the basic policy
tools in this area which are so
important and in fact we cover the role
of utilities which we haven't had time
to talk about today but but have been
very important but I also include a
section on tracking policy development
and implementation and explain what are
some of the major reports that are
issued every year in this area and there
are actually great tools where you can
go into a country like South Korea and
one of the tools that I teach about
tracks policy across I think seven
different areas the status of the
building codes the status of working
with the utilities the status of having
some government lead by example programs
and so I'm not I will confess that I
can't sit here today and say here's
exactly what can be done with South
Korea but again you can go in and look
in a very objective systematic manner to
see where things stand of different
policies because there's about seven
major policy areas for building energy
efficiency and what is happening in
countries around the world and that
that's what I would suggest to find out
so that where things stand in terms of
the mandatory building code appliance
standards working with utilities etc in
the webinar today you spoke about the
importance of intelligent buildings and
that being one of the pillars of this
course let's take a few moments to talk
about that can you discuss what the role
of machine learning and artificial
intelligence informatics why are their
roles in building energy efficiency can
you give some specific examples that our
viewers can look into so at a general
sense machine learning informatics is
there
- we can only be enabled if there are
mechanisms or components that actually
collect the data so that that is step
zero do you actually have sensors there
are they connected in a way to a central
system so that there is the system that
can just all this data there is data
that is created within the building
there is data that is created
surrounding the building and then there
is data that would have impact on the
building but comes from outside streams
so let's call that weather data for for
example or even traffic data and what
you would want to be able to do is you
would want to be able to collect all
this and then start looking for patterns
and you want to start to be able to
build a history so that you can actually
make predictions and then based on those
predictions and if you implement those
predictions see to what extent they
actually make the difference that you're
looking for there's a lot of work
actually at Lawrence Berkeley National
Lab that is trying to think about
buildings as a whole system and to what
extent machine learning tools can be
actually connected to physics based
tools to bring about a whole building
and more accurate approach in terms of
specifics we can talk about that do you
have any specifics do you want to get
into right now I will mention two areas
one is this is a plug for another
wonderful Stanford professor dr. Rishi
James not with us today but he runs here
at Stanford the urban informatics lab
and is doing some of the most
cutting-edge work on looking at
buildings looking at them in urban
environments and then looking at how
you're able to bring in machine learning
and so we were fortunate enough to have
dr. Jain available and in the
unintelligent efficiency we include an
interview specifically with him and what
he's really looking at is developing
completely new methodologies and
approaches that can take in information
about buildings across entire urban
areas and then understand in some ways
how the buildings are interacting with
one another that if it's a tall building
that may be shadowing another building
and that can affect the energy you see
so there is some very interesting work
going on in this area the other thing
that I'll mention is that we were
fortunate enough to work with not just
our national labs and leading
organizations in this area but with a
number of companies as well and again we
have many case studies we had one with a
company called clockworks where it is
doing it is installing sensors and
intelligent information systems across
buildings globally and so they are now
through that information starting to
understand and and really think about
for example predictive failure of
specific types of components and being
able to utilize millions of data points
that they now have to then as I said
utilize some machine learning and really
improve where you can go into your OEM
so it's again very exciting where you
can combine some of the cutting-edge
areas with traditional buildings and
think about how can we move forward so
when we think about a massive amount
information and a large number of people
I think two common concerns that arise
are cyber security and privacy I was
wondering if you can discuss how these
could be incorporated when designing the
next set of solutions for building
energy efficiency I'll take a stab and
us to add on data privacy
is hugely important as is cybersecurity
and we can't minimize if we are suddenly
getting a whole lot more information
about what's going on in our buildings
as well as outside factors that
influence them how are we going to
protect in these two areas and this is
where in my area specialty policy
becomes so important we do have a lot of
policies that have been developed but
are changing about thinking about the
data protections but I for one and
somebody who thinks that we really have
technical solutions to a lot of the data
privacy concerns and that we do not need
to say that we aren't going to really
take advantage of information about
building operations energy usage what's
going on in the buildings because we
can't protect that information we really
have safeguards that we can use and so
what has to happen is that the policies
develop and this is an area where I've
been a strong advocate that if you're a
long time policy maker like me you have
to actually spend time understanding
where the technology is moving to
understand how you can have policies
that take advantage of the technology
and our not an impediment and with cyber
security again that is actually somewhat
of an interesting area that Steve
teaches about it in the course with them
the data servers I don't know if you
want to mention let's also be clear eyed
that yes it needs to be considered and
what I would advocate for is standards
and when companies are thinking about
creating devices and when they're
thinking about what kinds of clouds or
networks they'll actually want to use
that those become primary and by design
features that they consider upfront
right now the the standards where it
comes to different devices especially
when it comes to consumer electronic
devices those can be all over the place
now if they're I would actually advocate
for the let's call it the private sector
or the industry to take a best step
forward because it's actually in their
best interest to be able to become
trustworthy in the eyes of consumers and
those that are actually trustworthy are
the ones that I think will have
strategic advantage over over those that
are that are not so it really is up to
yes
policy absolutely but industry as well
needs to step up and not just wait for
policy to happen and then they complain
about it but it takes steps aggressively
for Standardization and for best
practices when it comes to privacy and
cybersecurity and then also be willing
to help educate policy makers as well
because on your own
both constituencies will fail together
then there's a fighting hope we have
about a couple business left so I
thought we can address some questions on
financing there's a very specific
question here what are your thinking
when it comes to C pace financing it's
continuing to gain market traction but
hasn't quite reached a potential that
some would have hoped one viewer asks
I'm going to be brief and one thought
that I have when it comes to commercial
pace is salience e that perhaps those
who either have control over the
building may not have control over the
let's call it you have you have an
occupant who may not have the right
ability or the position to actually
advocate for a change in the building so
there is a let's call it
principal-agent problem there or you
have someone who owns a smaller building
commercial property and it's just not
salient to them so I would argue that at
least on the marketing side and more
cases of success needs to be promoted to
that what I would rightly admit is a
fractionated market now how do you
essentially go to different kinds of
small and medium enterprises and say
that commercial pace is actually
providing savings and is actually not
that hard to implement upfront so I'm
just gonna leave it there in the
interest of time we talked more about it
in the course but that's my feeling on
commercial pace at a high level anything
else and as our final question we've
gone through a lot today
what kind of conversations are necessary
to have traditional financing
institution create new financial options
for building energy efficiency this let
me start off by saying the good news is
conversations are happening again to
date myself I started off 40 years ago
and this was an area where we thought
about technology back then it was
insulation and we thought about policies
how can we work with utilities and
develop incentive programs those were
sort of the first basics but in the last
10 years and in the last five years the
conversations now do involve finance to
a great deal because it's understood if
all we're thinking about is what is
going on with the government and what's
going on with technology we have left
out a key sector so that's the first one
I would say is that the great news is
that we are having conversations the
other thing that Steve mentioned
getting of the webinar is thinking about
all the various stakeholders and that's
when you start to look at the finance
area you start to understand what a
broad variety of people there are that
are involved in the finance area and so
as in many things in this particular
discipline of building energy efficiency
there is no magic one solution that the
best finance efforts now are targeting
who is doing leases and how can we
really encourage the use of green leases
what is the finance for different types
of buildings that we're building on the
type a large scale skyscraper is very
different from the finance for a home
and so again the best efforts that I see
are where you have particular programs
that work closely with those entities
within a particular type of a building
segment understand what the market
players are understanding what motivates
people and then develops programs that
are available and publicize them and
then as rigorous about the feedback of
what's working and what's not working
our challenge is that we do have
successful examples in this area of
bringing in innovation in finance to
really improve the efficiency of both
existing and new buildings but we've got
to scale up and that's where it becomes
an area of how can the finance community
through many of their global
organizations really get involved as
well as how can you be working with the
policy side don't Steve and just to add
on that and this is the intersection of
intelligent efficiency and finance and
this is where solutions then can become
bankable because if you want to release
finance if you want to make capital
available you want to know what are what
are the risks involved and if you
actually have data and you don't
necessarily have what you have
four which is a black box then you can
actually track and verify has a solution
actually done what it's supposed to do
if it's not again because of intelligent
efficiency can you make fine tune
adjustments along the way as opposed to
doing a one-shot deal and then not being
entirely sure on what you're getting out
of it that democratization of of let's
call it data especially at the
residential level I think could you'll
see a lot of new financing tools because
that data will start existing on mass
Diane and Steve on behalf of the energy
innovation and emerging technology
program I would like to thank you for
sharing your insights and experience on
the challenges and opportunities in
building energy and efficiency and I
turn it back to Anita and well thank you
for joining us today and moderating the
questions for our presenters if you in
the audience if you found this
presentation to be helpful in any way we
do encourage you to share the recording
with your colleagues friends and family
or whoever you think you will find this
useful thanks for taking the time to
join with us today and have a great rest
of your day